it is the advan season employment and
time to visit the Christmas market
around the six hundred year old town
hall and the vramen worland the
Hanseatic cities landmark together
they've been listed as a unesco world
heritage site since 2004 over 160 stands
set against the historic backdrop draw
more visitors every year many want to
try typical blame and specialties like
peppermint gluten and curly kale blamin
style I was fun it's part of the party
season especially if you like hearty our
dishes curly kale is the quintessential
Braman winter dish the vitamin packed
vegetable grows in the region for
instance on horse Lewis farm the curly
leaf cabbage originated in the eastern
Mediterranean region where it was grown
some 2,000 years ago in Germany it's a
favorite mainly in the north it's also
popular in Central Europe North America
and Africa horse tour doesn't like to
experiment when it comes to preparing it
for me kale goes best with cooked or
smoked sausage cured pork and bacon but
when they start molding que Linda can
reform I'm not so sure I could eat that
it's gotta get some Frost because then
it turns the starch into sugar
this typical bremen winter dish can be
found on the Christmas market beside the
River visa head chef eggert liberal
prepares the kale for the stand just
across the way in his restaurants
kitchen he agrees with the farmer about
the role of frost frost is versa frost
is better for the kale they've always
said that kale tastes best once it's got
a really good frost and so on that's
what it should be harvested and the
bitter compounds are at a minimum which
one's ever mini myung the kale has to be
washed and the stems removed what comes
next difference from region to region in
northern Germany but in Bremen it goes
like this didn't even need to be Bernie
we saute the onions in oil and add the
kale clued up fool then we pour on some
rocks such as cured pork broth cook it
for about an hour and add clip and
smoked sausage season it with salt sugar
a little pepper some nutmeg and finally
we add a little mustard nothing nothing
listen dental tool then the whole thing
has to simmer for two hours blamen pinko
is a smoked fatty sausage with oats and
barley groats it used to be made and
smoked at home the blame and term brown
kale for the green kale originated when
it was cooked over an open fire the
smoke colored it brown
from 1545 there are records of the city
of Bremen holding an official kale feast
as a kind of banquet held every februari
in Bremen City Hall it's an important
social event in the region blame ins
histories closely tied to the Hanseatic
era and shipping the Christmas market on
the banks of the basil river with its
medieval themed stores relives this
Golden Age the stallholders dressed like
Hanseatic merchants certainly know all
about traditional kale dishes the first
thing i'd recommend will be allspice
it's typical for curly kale wooden
Pinkel uncombed up after a stroll around
the historical old town of the market
stalls a stop to warm up it's just the
thing I get verbal stand offers genuine
plamen curly kale to go
[Music]
mikuni idea behind the kale box is that
you can take it and walk around the
Christmas market with it the advantages
are that it keeps your hands warm you
can eat it on the run and you don't have
to get it all over yourself and kick
acne kale goes with fresh smoked pork
chops boiled sausage and potatoes but
how does it taste from the kale box to
go it's partially delicious I think so
too can't do without it being mr
mandela's Bremen's always worth the trip
from the Christmas market is just
fantastic the riverbank is wonderful in
the downtown has its charm the northern
German city of laminin winter is a fairy
tale come true
[Music]